[Music]
nine days that's how long Donald Trump
has to respond to a new motion filed by
special counsel Jack Smith earlier today
Smith is asking the Supreme Court for an
expedit ruling on whether Trump has
presidential immunity for his actions
related to his objections to the results
of the 2020 election of course all The
Usual Suspects say it's all about making
sure the trains run on
time I do think it's a smart move Jake I
think it's a necessary move in fact
because this is as a practical matter
the only real way Jack Smith can hold on
to his current trial date which is March
4th 202 four it's his only chance of
keeping this case on track now that's a
load of bunk is it's notable right that
in his request Jack Smith says it's
important to decide it quickly but he
never gives any reason as to why the
only sensible explanation is that Smith
filed this request because he wants
Trump tried convicted and sentenced
before the 2024 election joining me now
chrisopher landow Chris argu before the
court and several times and also clerk
for justices Thomas and Scalia Chris um
explain this for us all right well it's
good to be here Laura the special
Council filed two motions today one was
an extraordinary motion to have the
Supreme Court decide this important
immunity issue before the court of
appeals I mean the district court we
have three levels in our system district
court court of appeals Supreme Court the
normal path is for the case to go to the
court of appeals Jack Smith wants the
Supreme Court to basically take that
case before the court of appeals has
even decided it why decide well I think
it's obvious the mask is coming off
Laura that this is about election
interference as you just said this is
all about the timetable that they want
to get Trump convicted before the 2024
election so you have to speed it up this
is high usual look they brought an
incredibly unprecedented case never
before in American history has anything
like this uh come up through the legal
system obviously Trump has legal
defenses like I was President then and
and uh there's very tricky immunity
questions okay instead of having the the
legal process play itself out like it
usually does they're insisting that
there is imperative public importance in
this Tri public importance is that
Biden's down in like five swing States
it's it Laura it is one of the most
deing things as an americ
to see that we are really in a Banana
Republic where this is again there's no
way to explain this other than election
interference they want a DC jury
essentially to decide the 2024 election
by having this jurisdiction where by the
way in the last election uh Biden got
92% of the votes and Trump five so they
want to tell the rest of the country oh
no Trump was criminally convicted in DC
are you going to vote for a convict
victed felon I mean this is all a setup
and again the legal system whoever's
right or wrong on some of these legal
issues we have a process and I think it
is particularly important in an election
case like this to make sure that the
special counsel crosses his tees and
dots his eyes Congress why doesn't
Congress bring him uh to testify on
Capitol Hill where is the accountability
Congress has a role here this is why
Justice Galia thought all of this was
basically unconstitutional whole special
coun they're account to no the Biden
justice department acts I mean this is
such a charade like oh no it's not us
it's this special Council who's doing it
yeah well Politico just reported moments
ago Chris that Smith has extracted data
from the cell phone Trump used while he
was in the White House and plans to
present evidence of his findings to the
DC jury to demonstrate how Trump used
the phone in the weeks during which he
attempted to subvert the I mean this is
what it is now in a presidential
election year you're going to take the
cell phone of the guy who's beaten the
other guy by how many points Laura again
I mean come on you know there's no
question that January 6 if Trump is the
nominee will be a major issue but the
Democrats don't want to fight this in
the political Arena they want to say oh
no this is a criminal case folks this is
you know this is the the mighty Halls of
Justice this is again this motion to the
Supreme Court can only be explained by
their desire on timing there's no
imperative public need to have this
trial in March of next year what's the
imperative public need on that no it's
convenient politically because otherwise
it's very unlikely given normal judicial
uh procedures and processes that this
won't be decided before the election and
that's the worst of all worlds for them
the voters voters don't seem to buy into
any of this well you know I mean listen
we you know we'll see what happens I
have to say the one law that they can't
manipulate is the law of intended
consequences and so far it's not worked
that well for them on this Chris landow
you made something complicated really
understandable great to see you as
always always a pleasure thanks for
having me hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else